Wow
[Music]
it's Sunday which means Doctor Who and
it is time for me to do a review of a
classic Doctor Who episodes and my
supporters over on patreon selected for
me this time the two doctors I think
this is the last multi Doctor story that
I needed to see so actually no idea when
I'll get to it but I can finally do a
ranking of the multi Doctor stories now
hey there we go
but yeah so this happened during Colin
Baker's time as the doctor so during the
six doctors era and we have him teaming
up with Patrick Troughton the second
doctor so how did this go oh my god okay
you know it's funny I've I've seen some
bad episodes of Doctor Who new and
classic and I've even seen some episodes
of classic that like our are touted as
like the were like the twin dilemma I
always see Terra's like one of the worst
episodes of Doctor Who ever
I think the twin dilemma was a lot
better than this holy cow okay um trying
to be spoiler free at least initially on
this trust me
he shouldn't care if I spoil it but yeah
whatever before I even try and get into
the plot because I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna be really sporadic and like miss
things are like I had such a hard time
focusing on this paying any degree of
attention I'd like not even like with a
phone in my hand like I'm distracted
like just looking at the screen my brain
was checking out like no I don't want to
process this information so I'm probably
gonna have a hard time remembering
character names or you know I'm sure
I'll miss some details but
oh dear God okay so plot-wise actually
you know what before I even try and
recount the plot what is the major
appeal of multi doctor stories it's
seeing the doctor interact with himself
guess what there's almost none of in
this story like at all
hardly any we start off with the second
doctor I'm travelling with Jamie and
it's kind of adorable
how I mean I know that the low
definition of of the recordings and TVs
at the time you know was a lot more
forgiving than now but it's kind of
adorable that they thought they could
get away with not only having Patrick
Troughton
but also Frasier Heinz back is Jamie and
think that audiences wouldn't notice
they look twenty years older and then
again I made I guess you know a lot of
the the error of those guys were lost so
I guess maybe they figured people didn't
have the comparison to be able to make
in a lot of cases but Wow
okay so we start with the two of them
and immediately I am confused because
the they arrived at this sort of space
science research station and the doctor
confronts the guy who is running it and
apparently the doctor the second doctor
mind was sent by the Time Lords to look
into what he's doing because he's
supervising some experiments in
time-travel that have the Time Lords
concerned the second I'd like I know the
doctor has been an agent of the Time
Lords
usually reluctantly at a few points but
the second doctor is working for the the
Time Lord showed up for the very first
time
second doctors era in his very last
story and he was terrified of them and
they immediately sentenced him to
regeneration and banishment on earth
because of his tendency to you know mess
around with time in history that doctor
is working with the Time Lords and I
know they toss off something like about
how it's all deniable and like it's an
unofficial capacity but no that doesn't
go over this no sense whatsoever so
there's that first of all and so
apparently this is a huh this is a
really small cast for the fact that this
is a three-part story I'll be coming
back to that fact how long the sign is
probably a few times but so the the
doctor and Jamie get here the he the
station has a basically kind of a she's
officially an assistant but she's like
she's super smart because she's been
augmented by this by this professor sort
of character that the doctor is you know
initially they're confronting and she is
like super smart but apparently she was
and she's an evolved and smartened form
I'm sorry mega genius actually use the
phrase mega genius form of a very base
kind of instinctive not especially
intelligent or nuanced race a dragon I
believe is what they call them and for a
point of reference we have another a
dragon character who is the chef on
board this thing and he yeah I'll come
back to him too but he gives us a
baseline for what he's like he is
obsessed with figuring out how to cook
basically any living thing he encounters
how would it taste what's the best way
to prepare it so obviously he sees Jamie
and immediately wants to cook him and so
that's our comparison but her the the
woman who's been sort of upgraded she is
articulate and intelligent but the
doctor is super worried about her making
an argument that because of what she was
evolved from because that base level was
so aggressive and single-minded and
barbaric I suppose that she still can't
be trusted which I'm actually gonna
pause first I can pick at that because
that seems like a really weird argument
in the first place because I mean
everything is evolved from something
primitive in barbarity yes I know this
isn't a case of like generations she's
evolved over it you know it's it's one
person being pushed further along but
the thing that sort of annoys me about
it is that this is the first time we're
seeing this race so far as I know and I
find it really uncomfortable when the
doctor makes a blanket statement about
an entire race or species of alien as
being well honestly anything negative
other than the Daleks he has every basis
to say horrible things about the Daleks
and you know what I'll give it to the
Cybermen too because of you know the
whole conversion they end since they're
so augmented you acted that actually is
kind of a case of met one met them all
actually in both cases but other than
that it kind of at least in for me it
goes against the nature of the doctor or
how I choose to think of the doctor when
he just blank it oh there you can't
trust any of them sort of statement like
I know we have a lot of like whole
species that are villains but to pick
say one that we see in this story we've
got the Sontarans and like the Sontarans
yes they're always dangerous when they
show up but we're also always dealing
with military
now it doesn't seem like some terms are
nothing but military but you could make
an argument that it's this class that is
the issue as opposed to the species as a
whole and I think in a lot of cases
we're dealing with just one really awful
person when we're dealing with a lot of
yo or an awful group but having the
doctor like make a blanket statement
about the species as a whole it just
felt wrong to me anyway he turns out to
be right because she doesn't thang
betray them she lets Sontarans onto the
station we get to son time the fact that
they had no money to make that like this
is the one much more than a wobbly set
this story this war it's lack of money
on its sleeve you could tell that they
had no money for anything and I think
it's actually most reflected in how
small the caste is because as I said
we've got we've got the two doctors
we've got they've each got a companion
we've got the professor guy we've got
the woman we've got the chef we've got
two Sontarans and then we've got these
this Spanish woman and this English
would be actor I don't know why like it
all I'm gonna go through a whole lot of
divergences of stuff that is just bad
and wrong with this I haven't even gone
through synopsize in the story oh okay
so the second doctor gets captured and
kidnapped and the this because of the
time experiments going on in the place
where that happens his capture and the
things they're doing to him kind of
reverberates down his own timeline so
the Sixth Doctor Colin Baker sort of
feels that something is wrong and goes
to investigate that now they have
captured the second doctor because they
need part of his genetics in order to
figure out time travel because
apparently and this actually I thought
was kind of neat is there is a symbiotic
biological link between the doctor and
his TARDIS that enables himself
and those and those in his immediate
proximity ie is campaigns to travel
safely but if someone who does not have
that in their genes or isn't right next
to someone who does have that in their
genes if they try and time travel you
know even in a device that is capable of
it
they will disintegrate or dematerialize
or just kind of fall apart that's kind
of an interesting thing I think it's
completely inconsistent with a fair
number of stuff that's going on
definitely since that episode probably
probably probably even before but that's
so that's kind of neat but they need his
genetic information to be able to
perfect this time travel time travel
technology the Sontarans are expecting
use of it you have bickering between the
the various villains a whole crap ton of
this is set in just this old house on
earth because of course it is because
that's a cheap location the doctor gets
messed with and tinkered in so the
second doctor gets further messed with
and they attempt to turn him into an
androgen which means he like the chef
character now becomes obsessed with food
and the two of them just IQ this is all
okay now I'm getting into water calls
what would be considered spoilers like
this thing is a mess and like on every
single conceivable level it's a mess
like I I know there are classic who fans
who feel that I really get overly harsh
on the the budgetary restrictions of
these things but like there's having not
a lot of money and there's no only how
to work with the fact that you don't
have a lot of money building building a
three-part multi Doctor story around a
cast this small and this few locations
especially when they keep referring to
people who aren't there we're getting
reference to the Sontaran fleet or we
get repeated reference like to two other
scientists whose work all this is being
built on who worked at the first at the
Science Space Station but who we never
see at all cuz they would
to pay actors to play that and coming
back to the Sontarans they look awful
like that's not me comparing to now
that's me comparing two earlier
appearances of the Sontarans compared to
links in the time warrior first time
Sontarans ever appeared these guys look
awful I strongly suspect that we're
dealing with the same problem that they
had when they brought back Davros the
first time I think it was in destiny of
the Daleks where they've got basically
old masks and suits made for actors who
aren't returning to play these creatures
again which means that instead of
creating a new mask to fit whoever the
heck it is we've got a mask for somebody
else and it looks awful and barely moves
that's what happened with that Ross I'm
fairly certain that's what happened here
they just looked terrible and they move
awful and the performances are actually
you know what
performances are fine oddly enough like
what I actually stop and think about it
there's nothing wrong with the
performances in this there's a lot wrong
with the writing like top to bottom and
and there's some other of the the things
that just go on it okay so this I'm not
gonna blame on the actress I'm gonna
blame it on the writing I parry why is
parry travelling with the doctor
like I don't mean why did she initially
start travelling him why is she still
because she does not seem to enjoy being
with Colin Baker's doctor at all they're
not having fun before or she's not
having fun at least before the adventure
starts because he wants to fish and
she's bored out of her mind
she is nervous and antsy and not at all
excited at the possibilities of the
danger on the space she she doesn't seem
to like to be around him so I mean I
understand that you know there was
intended to be the gradual softening of
their relationship and all that but when
he doesn't seem to appreciate having her
around and she doesn't seem to like him
either that just doesn't work like it
would have worked if she was
you know trying to bring a little more
nice as I'm but she just seems fed up
with him and her outfit is also look I
know it sounds kind of piggish for me to
point this out but I'm sorry the outfit
they put her in for this
she's got cleavage you could lose a
small dog end it's really distracting
actually and then like I said though the
performances are fine the guy who plays
the cook again like I somebody's gonna
put his net the character's name in the
comments and I cuz I like I told you
that is it I am recording this as soon
as I finished it because these details
are leaked like my brain is rejecting
this thing but he is very obviously
having a lot of fun and he's putting a
lot of effort into the performance that
he's giving me and it's it's a full body
performance it's not phoned in
definitely and it's not even like bad or
campy but the problem is the character
is so one note you just oh god and then
he and the second I'm getting I'm
getting properly into spoilers now do
you care I hope you don't care you don't
want to watch this so maybe by this I
mean that you do want to watch this keep
watching maybe not I don't know I
Oh God so the the second doctor is
turned into part and Rogan and he and
this the the this chef they go off to a
restaurant and it's this whole extended
thing like so much time is eaten up in
this you've got this explanation of how
to get to town like and the town's not
even that far away but like we have to
stop and take like a minute two solid
minutes of them stopping a truck and the
driver gets out and this and the chef
hits him with a stick and knocks him out
except he doesn't hit him in the head he
hits I'm like in the middle of his back
somehow that knocks them out okay and
then you know they go down and they
bicker for a while like that's another
solid minute of them bickering before
they get to a restaurant it's just why
and I know why
for whatever reason whatever glitch of
scheduling they set aside three
episodes for this now that might not
sound a lot because if you're used to
classic ooh you probably know that most
of the time for classic Who episodes
were about I was gonna say half an hour
but you know they weren't really they
were 20 to 24 minutes usually it's about
22 minutes and most of those stories
were four parts and up during Colin
Baker's run they tried it a different
way and they did basically double length
episodes and did fewer of them so a
two-parter during the Colin Baker era is
the equivalent to a four-part ER for the
doctors prior to that and so when I say
there are three episodes devoted to this
I mean is the equivalent of six episodes
of any earlier doctor it's over two
hours and and I don't like me two hours
of you know factoring in for no just two
hours no commercial just over two hours
it felt a lot longer because it just
goes nowhere it spins wheels and it
sinks so much time into characters like
this friggin wannabe actor who shows up
again as the waiter at the restaurant
and then just get stabbed like what did
they think it was funny I we and we
think a lot of time at Himalayas because
he had set up ahead of time him in this
and the Spanish woman and that whole
thing is we it's like these are the sort
of characters that do show up in classic
who from time to time you know the side
characters who aren't really involved
until they sort of stumble into things
except usually when they work they it's
something that is set on an alien or
future or past setting where they can
give us more context and more flavor for
the world we're in this is this section
is set in modern-day Europe we don't
need these people to give us a point of
reference for what things are like here
in that that's just what it oh my god
I I could go through and I could pick
apart thing after thing after thing
after thing okay one other really
nitpicky thing and then maybe I'll like
close out cuz that aside from the fact
that the performances are solid not
great but solid I have nothing good to
say about this thing the writing is
atrocious it's awful and on every level
the dialogue the plot the pacing so one
other thing I just want to note this
because this this was an early indicator
of how bad this was gonna be so the
second doctor in Jamie the TARDIS
materializes in the chef's kitchen and
they get out Me's
isn't sure who they are now he's got on
his belt this big-ass sword
it's a scimitar it's a full-size
scimitar and he reaches behind himself
to get a knife you have a sword on you
if you want to threaten them why are you
reaching front you hadith and that kind
of stuff is just throughout on top of
everything else that I've mentioned this
thing is plotting it is pointless
it's not fun it doesn't give you the one
job of a multi doctor story which is the
doctor interacting with himself it's
just painful like I've still got a lot
of stuff to see so I'm not saying this
will always be the case but as of right
now this is the worst doctor who
definitely classic possibly even knew
who no not worse than hell-bent cuz how
they like actively makes me furious but
maybe short of that like this is worse
than gods and monsters or the sorry love
and monsters seriously because at least
eleven monsters only eats up 45 minutes
of your time
oh dear Lord the two doctors have you
seen it I hope
not but if you have or you have of us
you want to share drop something down
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do I'm not even gonna
bother mentioning like and subscribe
anymore I by all means go ahead and do
that but I would recommend that you
follow me either on Twitter or Facebook
or or patreon ha because um you will
have those places get the updates for
all new videos where as you just
subscribe
I can't guarantee it's gonna show up in
your subscription fees because YouTube
is being a jerk again so whatever your
thoughts are drop them down there and
just remember folks you are the council
I just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]